i got i got to say a man you know i i
was i had a brief stint as a democrat
when i voted for obama and then felt
this illusion
because it was like it was war all over
again i don't i don't much care for the
republican party
i'm i think donald trump has done enough
like some good things anti-war peace
deals
pulling our troops back that i'm i'm
happy with but i really do feel like
it's been the democratic party the
entire time oh absolutely
it's been first of all they're the party
of slavery oh listen listen
but well just real quick what i want to
get to is a lot of people say that the
party's switched and i'm like no they
went subversive
right because when you say black lives
matter want to destroy the family i'm
like they're keeping up the legacy of
destroying minority
communities right they are very
crafty it's what i call a beautiful ugly
the precision and the strategy and the
tactics
oh man as a as a person that plays chess
i'm like wow you guys really got that
off
you convince all of the black people to
donate
to black lives matter and 700 million
dollars of that went to the biden
campaign well that's not that it
not necessarily it's a it's more
complicated than that it is
but i'm paraphrasing and simplifying it
maybe
overseas let me let me give the best
context like context i can
yeah so bla so they say black lives
matter is not political
yet for some reason act blue which is
the democrats fundraising arm
is managing their funds all of the
resources now now act blue says that
money that isn't claimed
goes to act blue so i'll put it this way
if you donate the black lives matter a
portion of your donation goes to act
blue
and if if black lives matter doesn't
claim the donation properly under some
circumstances act blue keeps it
which funds the democrats fundraising
infrastructure
so it's not going to joe biden but it is
providing the democratic party a
fund-raising arm
and the fund raising their
infrastructure right and the
fundraising all of the democrats after
they so
after you lose or you're out of the
running
you can then donate that money to
whichever candidate you choose to
and we all know where it's a money
laundering scheme it's a ponzi scheme
so i think it's worse than that it
absolutely is because ponzi schemes if
you do them right
it's only a scheme like um yeah my
i i i'm from the south side of chicago
and i know a lot of people who didn't
make it out
yeah and i think i i had good parents i
was lucky yeah and so when i see
you know when i see what was one factor
in my success
and getting away and moving out and i'm
not saying everybody there's doing bad i
mean some middle class living right but
a lot of people
some like i know a couple people who
od'd one person who i
knew when i was younger is dead from an
overdose people joined gangs
and i can see that they had bad families
yeah now it's not always true i mean
some of these people had a regular
family and still got caught up just
choices but when i see black lives
matter say they want to disrupt the
nuclear family
i'm saying you're convincing white
suburban people to donate to an
organization that's
actively hurting black communities by
doing that
and then say there's no systemic racism
they're making it it is literally
manufactured you see the example of it
you see that actress recently she came
out in support for donald trump
she said if you were voting for joe
biden hillary clinton kamala harris
these are the people who have been in
government for decades who literally
created the systemic racism correct
and now you're voting for them you're
part of the problem beautiful ugly
the fact that they could trick is the
movie um
i think it was i forget which movie it
was but the quote was
the biggest trick that the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world that
he didn't exist yeah and it's the same
concept
it's no no we like kamala's wearing
timberlands getting off the plane so
she's clearly cool
she's clearly down for the cause this is
the same woman that
didn't want to let non-violent cannabis
guys that were locked up for weed not
let them out of jail because
california needed the like free slave
labor they were she wanted to pay him a
dollar an hour to put out wildfires bam
not even a job it was
life-risking right this is the same
person that when she was in the
breakfast club laughs about it
yes i smoked every now and then so the
beauty of it is
man y'all really pulled that chest move
off the ugly is
the intent and the deed and the actions
and the outcome
as a as an objective person i'm able to
go
oh man you was really gonna rob me that
night you i saw it i
you were good up until you telegraphed
and i could see you in the bar in the
big mirror
i could see you talking with the dude
over there this happened to me in new
orleans you know what i'm saying i was
like oh y'all were good you almost had
me
the objective in me is like oh man y'all
really got that off
the ugly in me is like man that's really
messed up yeah you know and i'm i'm i'm
emotionally unmoved by it
one because i'm aware of it and two we
at war
and if you're emotional in the middle of
a war that's how you got your head blown
i love military tactics but i hate war
right so so
uh what do you think about donald trump
um
i like him on
so i don't i don't really think about
donald trump so so
do you uh what about the republicans
some of them are cool most of them are
rhinos
yup yup some of like i don't i don't
think that they know what
they're statists i don't think that a
lot of them know what
i don't think that they know that
they're we this is a republic
i don't think that they know that the
smallest republic is the individual
i don't think that they like their
constituents
i think my man larry sharp came to the
solution a summit
he said most politicians actually hate
you
because they see you as like in the way
of their aims that's why they jump from
the public to private sector
make the rule this so i can jump back in
the private sector and benefit from this
it's not about people anymore man it's
about it's like a a point system
right these these politicians and not
all of them there's there's a handful
that are good a handful of our
republicans but it's like eight
right i basically use that number
because there were eight people who
sided with trump on withdrawing the
troops yeah
eight republicans and three democrats
and i'm like y'all are cool not
completely because there's probably
things i disagree with
but you have very very few of these
people and the rest of them
they just want the keys to the castle
right so what the way they look at the
constituents
is they have a chart saying here's how
you're swinging so they don't they don't
care about you
necessarily most of these people they
care about what am i up
right and they say oh you're down four
oh i'm down fork how can we get me up
three
where are some timberlands exactly
that's purely because they want to get
re-elected
right there's another reason for term
limits so so i asked thomas massey about
this term limit thing in in congress
right
he said that would be a cotton candy
solution and
i'm like what do you mean he's like
cotton candy's like it's you taste it
and it does it is it's kind of food-like
but it doesn't really sustain you he was
like you know he pulled out his um
his uh congress like whatever card they
give him in the number
right he's like this number means that
there's this many people i'm this many
people senior
so this amount of people have actually
been in congress
less than me wow and so it's not about
term limits it's what you
do with the time that you get there
right right
um but that means the reason why the
term limits
they're able to pull off a lot of this
beautiful ugly and be there for 50 years
joe biden and not do anything is because
the people are not educated about what
makes a good public servant
hence systematically taking civics and
social studies
out of schools right you don't even know
what that process is
you know what i mean and so the term
limit thing would be because then okay
let's
flip side to that coin what if there's a
guy or a woman in there doing great
that's like up you're doing great time's
up and it's like then you get like a
complete
trash politician right after them so
that
pendulum swings both ways back to your
question about president trump
i love him on first shouts to him for
freeing a good friend of mine angela
stanton king
he gave her a presidential pardon
she's running for congress in district
five in atlanta john lewis's old seat
oh wow she came to the solutionary
summit
everybody should check into her she's
atlanta as they come
and i would trust somebody like her in
that seat
that wants to protect children that
wants to push
actual conservative values and serve the
people of atlanta
right he gave her a presidential pardon
last i know like racists don't do that
right so this whole like is he racist i
don't
look i don't care if he is i don't know
him personally don jr follows me we chop
it up here and there
you know what i'm saying don's a shooter
i like that i think don should run for
like mayor of new york or something
that's what i think um
but i don't evaluate politicians based
on
like if i like them yeah i like i don't
need to like you you're a plumber
i hire you i got a clog like get the
clog out
now you'll do a job and i'm like bro not
only did you get the clog out he showed
me like in two months you're gonna have
a clog in this one
you don't have to hire me now but let me
tell you why and
two months later if i get the clock i'm
like this guy was on it right and i'm
hiring him
i don't care if he's got his butt crack
showing i don't care
did he get the clog out so so here's
what here's it's actually an analogy i
use for like a plumber
you got you hired two plumbers or two
plumbers coming your house give you a
quote
one guy he looks terrible his butt
cracks sticking out he won't stop
cussing
yeah but you know he's got a good record
like well actually you might have never
hired him before the other guys
look you know sharp but they're you know
they can't stop complaining about the
guy with the butt crack yeah
so you got one guy with a butt crack and
he's telling he's going to get it done
you hire him he starts getting it done
and these guys won't shut up
but they're demanding you give them the
contract while this dude's literally
trying to
and then they start hitting the guy
fixing the toilet and you're like let
him fix my toilet dude
he's getting it and they won't stop you
think i'm gonna ever give you a contract
again it's not happening but the
difference
of the plumber is that after the guy
fixes the clog then his job is to go out
on the street and represent you to the
neighborhood
and if he's a jerk that's a problem
well it could be but depending on
what your what your meter
of success is my so so for example
president obama is one of my favorite
politicians of all time i think he's a
great
symbol for melanated young people
especially
i think that you know the audacity of
hope and letters
to my father is like some of the best
reading i've ever done i like that he
was like the first president of like
harvard law whatever school that was
i think that that's dope i think he was
smooth i think that presidential beige
suit was
like the coldest suit ever right
i think that he he he got through things
that i would have been smack somebody in
the mouth behind
and for those reasons he's one of one of
my favorite politicians for those
reasons for that list
then i pan over to policy and then i go
no you you campaigned on
closing gitmo you didn't you campaigned
on
uh getting us out of iraq and
afghanistan you didn't
you campaigned on the patriot act being
the most horrible thing ever
you re-upped on it so when i look at
policy
i can evaluate you there's really hot
girls that i'm like oh man she's so hot
i would never touch her with a 10-foot
pole but she's
so hot and i would never touch her
because her
spirit is corrupt i can feel it is that
what you think about obama
i think that obama as a as a human
i don't know him i can only base it onto
his
symbolism and his substance bro you know
what i mean and
the substance of it i gotta disagree
with the what president trump
i think he has gotten things done great
in regards to business and the economy
i think that he's been attacked
tremendously more so than any president
that i've seen maybe
second maybe or first the they're
running neck and neck him and obama
depending on which side is attacking
right i agree with him on a lot of
things
i disagree i think his stance on guns
has been weak
i think that he's had more federal
restrictions on the second amendment
than obama in one term than obama didn't
do
and that's just me evaluating my
plumbers that's it
right obama's like a guy who go out on
the street everyone loves him so they're
like oh i love you have a great guy out
on the street but he can't fix the lead
no no no no no
and trump fixes the leak goes out and
yells at people and they're like i can't
stand him
or you because he's your plumber i'm
gonna tell you what obama was obama was
the guy who walked into your front door
the smile on his face and he was like
hey
and he winks and you're like oh this
guy's so amazing he's like i'm gonna go
make you all look good
walked to the rich people's houses and
winked at them and then walked over the
poor house and started smacking people
and kicking them around
and that was his foreign policy and then
he comes and he says
at your house i'll tell you what i look
great and i can snatch up your kids in
the middle of the night rendition them
in an off on an offshore oil rig you'll
never hear from them again
that's the national defense
authorization indefinite detention
provision
so i i hear exactly what you're saying
dude no he was he was smooth he was
he was charismatic he and and he
inspired people
and then when it came to policy he was
the same exact thing i saw in george w
bush this
is what this is our fault though
it's our fault yeah i agree with that we
we
are not making politicians afraid again
this is our job we are what is he
but is he i think so they've been
screaming non-stop
i think they've been i think they've
been screaming non-stop on the left
i think that for sure i think that but
they scream
that's what they do you know what i'm
saying i think that
i think that we ben should have had
people
out it's 19 20 years later afghanistan
it's over
like it's done it's done get him home
don't say get him home you are the
commander-in-chief
you are the commander-in-chief i think
that
do does he leave something to be desired
in regards to
his approach absolutely but then when i
look at
how the economy was humming oh yeah
i've made more legal money maybe or
maybe not
allegedly right with this being the case
those parts if you're being objective
that's that's how i view it
but i also am a one-issue voter and i
cannot ignore the fact that he has been
weak on the second amendment i was in
the front row
at the nra annual meetings when he first
was elected
and he was the first stan sitting
president to address
the nra convention i was literally in
the front row when he said
the eight-year assault on your second
amendment rights is coming to a crashing
halt
that's not the case that doesn't mesh
with and again
i'm not attacking them i'm not i'm this
is the plumber
you can't say that and then say
take the guns first due process later
that is not something that i want to
hear from
my commander-in-chief that is not what
our nation needs to hear
i think that what happens is because we
have become so complacent
with this two-party system that
everybody gets
barbecued up on july the 4th but george
washington and the boys
literally were like do not do a party
system yeah so i think now this time
this is the time that we should be
looking into
strengthening a third party yeah have
you ever heard me about that last night
have you ever read the original second
amendment
no i didn't i didn't know about this
until i actually looked at the bill of
rights and that we were i forgot what
this
what segment we were talking about and
there was originally 17 articles
proposed
it was because there were a lot of
people who were scared of a strong
federal government
like basically federalists so they said
okay we'll take these 17 things
a bunch of them didn't make it but the
original second amendment was very clear
that it i'm probably gonna get this
wrong so you know the gunners out there
super chat correct me if i'm getting it
wrong but basically said something like
if you it says uh you know a well
regulated militia being
you know necessary for a free state the
right to keep and bear arms should not
be restricted
and it said basically if somebody
doesn't want to join
you know military service in any way
doesn't mean they can't own a gun
i'm like why did you get rid of that
part i think it was because it like the
language banned conscription
yeah and so they ended up getting rid of
it they kept that
that you can see the spirit of what they
meant yeah they meant everybody should
have firearms everybody should be
should be armed and they get rid of this
one provision and now
now the left says oh but a
well-regulated militia means the
military
right right right but they clearly said
even if you don't want to you can keep
your weapon
here's the bigger part to that to me the
bill of rights was the double down to
say hey guys remember these are things
not granted by government nor can
government take them away
like just in case in a hundred years
everybody gets stupid
these list of things your right to
express yourself and then the right to
defend what you just said
it's not granted by government it's not
taken away they just did a good job of
studying governments prior to and
codifying human nature and natural law
thomas paine john locke those dudes were
somewhere else you know i liking them
they're not
singers to my knowledge but when you
hear
bohemian rhapsody by queen freddie
mercury was somewhere else
to write those changeovers and that like
he was somewhere else you're saying like
it was profound like so good they must
have been
somewhere else they had hemp farms yeah
you know what i'm saying oh yeah and so
they
they were somewhere else in their
understanding of liberty
because they had seen one they just came
from a tyrannical government
and by studying these guys were not only
were they like
and they had their contradictions
because you notice i keep saying guys
there were no women so that's strike one
right these guys were like
craftsmen and builders and architects
and like
like guys that like made stuff that's
the power of creation
that's like the power of god you see
what i'm saying and they tied it into a
moral
compass feeling thing and to to double
down and say hey
we're going to make this extra list so
so we remember that we're
making this stuff to like check
government
so when we talk about what's a
bootlicker what's a statist
these are the people that think that
this is for the government to tell us
what to do
not us to put the government on time out
if they start reaching we are the
government
right and so that's the part that
um we've become we even though i'm not a
republican
or a democrat i am a libertarian
um with strong conservative values
strong conservative values and i'm cool
with if everybody else in the liberty
movement is like
yeah there should be open borders i'm
gonna go that's cool that you think that
i don't
right um this is why i say it's our
fault though because
we are not self-educating we are not the
information is there i got
five phones on me literally
the information's there the
conversations are being had
the geniuses have left their blueprints
you know this is why in 2022
i'm like 98 gonna just go be on my
planet
and do my thing i believe that americans
and this this hurts to say i believe
that americans are too soft
they're too marshmallow and we don't
want to do what's necessary when obama
got elected
i remember he was anti-war and i was
anti-war and there was a building
anti-war movement then he got elected
and there was no more movement the money
leaned on and the president can't do
anything if the people aren't surging
yeah it's our job yep and it's the same
thing with hillary
remember hillary used to like fight so
hard for universal health care
she used to fight for it then she
started getting funded by insurance
and that conversation stopped the at a
certain point
you got to look at what your legacy is
to me
if i picked like if i went hard left or
hard right
oh man i'd have a tv show like it would
like
i'm charismatic i'm handsome
right i'm reasonably smart if i picked a
side as opposed to being balanced
and objective like even in the chat
there's going to be as you guys
scroll through this there's going to be
people that are saying i'm insane
i'm a terrorist i'm one of those black
power dudes then there's going to be
people going he's a patriot what i'm
talking about i'm looking at right here
people being like this guy's awful and
another guy being like dude i was
cheering i can't believe this is awesome
you're an interesting dude man it's
layers it's context
it's contextual it's the the gray area
that is what most of us actually are
but we've been forced into picking one
of these sides and then we keep
again july 4th reference we keep going
america america america but the founding
fathers that we say that we support we
don't even have a conversation about
thomas paine who
who who shaped the minds of like damn
near all of those guys
you know what i mean and so when you
have someone such as myself or other
people that show up
that are in those gray areas and saying
i agree here i disagree
here i'm feeling this i'm not feeling
that those people get
vilified ridiculed on this side
depending on the conversation
and heralded and celebrated on this side
depending on the conversation and it
switches and it ebbs and flows
and i'm cool with that thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you